ne pas tomber ne pas tomber ne pas
tomber
[Musique]
fowler est venu de parler du wan pu
assister en termes de photos vidéos
alors ça fait un moment que je voulais
produit je sais je suis désolé voilà
maintenant on y arrive alors ça fait un
bon mois
bon moi facilement que j'utilise le mot
de plus histoire tant que smartphone
principal donc je connais franchement
bien je reste toujours sur ce que j'ai
dit j'adore ce smartphone mais vous
n'avez pas encore parlé de la partie
photo vidéo alors on va couper cette
vidéo en deux parties très organisé la
première partie c'est regarder un petit
peu est-ce qu'on en termes de logiciels
à l'intérieur on va faire un tour du
côté des spectres et rapidement très
très très très rapidement vous allez
voir logiciel de photo et franchement
cool très simple très simple ça marche
très très bien
et en fait de vous montrer ce que j'ai
shooté en photos toutes les vidéos je
vous emmener avec moi vous allez voir
franchement vous n'allez pas être au
bout de vos surprises par une puce
system l'arrière vous avez un double
module photo 16 mégapixels plus 20
mégapixels les deux ouvrant à f 1.7
il n'y a absolument pas de téléobjectifs
donc ici le zoom sera forcément
numérique l'idée du double module photo
c'est d'améliorer la qualité notamment
en photo nuit savent aussi travaillé
pour le mode portrait vous pouvez filmer
jusqu en 4k uhd moi ce que je vous
conseille franchement là dessus je vous
le dirais vous le verrez après c'est le
full hd full hd 1080p à 60 images par
secondes ça marche très bien vous avez
une stabilisation optique c'est vraiment
top
à l'avant ici vous avez une caméra de 16
mégapixels ouverture de f 2.0
ça marche pas mal ça va on n'a rien à
lui reprocher c'est pas complètement fou
fou mais ça fonctionne plutôt pas mal la
taille du pixel devant la caméra
principale c'est de 1,2 micromètres il
vous permet de capter un peu plus de
lumière et vous allez voir cet appareil
en faible luminosité
il ya eu un vrai beau progrès faits par
one plust qui fonctionne vraiment bien
au point de vue logiciel y arriver
l'extraordinaire photo vidéo les
paramètres sont franchement hyper simple
mode portrait mode n'y voyez vous avez
quatre modes
franchement il n'y a rien de bien dingo
là dessus vous et pour faire caméra
arrière caméra avant coucou c'est moi
vous repassez ici hop vous choisissez
4/3 plus grands ce que vous voulez voilà
en terme d'affichage votre retardateur
le flash pour le mode vidéo c'est pareil
vous arrivez ya un lien bien sorcier le
mode portrait rien
un bien sorcier non plus et le mode nuit
qui se retrouve directement ici ça
fonctionne si vous voulez avoir plus de
paramètres plus d'options vous arriver
là vous avez un autre projet pouvoir
gratter un peu plus de paramètres là
c'est vraiment pour ce que vraiment
envie de s'amuser à faire pas mal de
choses
vous pouvez venir le faire là là là par
contre c'est vraiment cool on peut même
faire des photos au format raw enfin ça
c'est si on veut aller un peu plus loin
c'est bien le mode accéléré mode
panorama ralenti le paramètre le mode
ralenti je vous montrais franchement
c'est pas génial génial
il faut beaucoup de lumière si vous
n'avez pas beaucoup de lumière la
qualité pas folle
[Musique]
donc d'un point de vue logiciel purement
logicielle ça fonctionne très très bien
maintenant ce que je vais faire c'est
que je vais vous emmener avec moi je
suis parti il ya quelques semaines à
marseille sur un week-end familial
j'ai filmé j'ai fait des photos j'ai
fait des vidéos et vous allez voir le
rendu est quand même assez top ça marche
très très bien notamment en conditions
de luminosité classique et même en
faible luminosité
on verra
k
sauf
et quand
[Musique]
mon oeil oui
ford ans
[Musique]
on est ou elliott là on est ou non
marché hier dimanche on est à marseille
à la plage oui on n'est pas trop mal
mais ça va je crois que c'est un faux ça
sapho crabe info craps ah ah ouais c'est
un faux comme ça
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on est à marseille ce
week-end en famille on en profite pour
tester la caméra douvaine plus si ce
n'est déjà parlé il ya un petit moment
donc là on va se faire différents plans
on va tester la photo de nuit on va
tester la photo normale aurait testé la
vidéo la vidéo de cette fille là ce soir
là la vidéo que la caméra principale
caméra rien de rien vous avez une vue
sur les plages de marseille on est
plutôt pas mal d'argent qui est un petit
resto on va continuer et puis vous allez
me dire ce que vous en pensez bien sûr
un bon commentaire elliott elliott
elle est pas mal on sucre avec crêpes la
viola 77 oh c'est pas une crêpe au
succès du du sucre avec jeudi la vidéo
de filmer en full hd à 60 images par
seconde pour moi franchement c'est le
meilleur compromis sur ce smartphone et
même les photos je les trouve
franchement bien vous avez du vrai
détails vrais détails dans l'image
ce que j'aime bien c'est que le
traitement logiciel est pas et pas sur
saturé vous n'avez pas des images qui
font au final un peu fait qu'ils sont
assez loin qu'on a là des fonds dans la
réalité
bien au contraire c'est très près la
réalité il est vrai les restitutions il
ya un vrai beau détails lorsque vous
allez regarder vos photos bien lorsque
vous allez foot et d'astrid un vrai beau
rendu ça je trouve ça vraiment bien
notamment sur la caméra arrière la
caméra de cellfish fonctionne mieux mais
c'est surtout au niveau de la caméra
arrière que le job se fait là dessus
en faible luminosité je trouve que les
photos fonctionne aussi bien et c'est
vraiment un des gros points forts de ce
one + 6 t c'est l'amélioration logiciel
va pas se mentir parce que des potes du
matériel ça bouge pas par contre du
point de vue logiciel il ya eu un beau
traitement fait aux niveaux des photos
faible luminosité
il ya vraiment un rendu qui est top
c'est vrai que c'est très très très
bluffant et lettres sur tout cas c'est
un reproche qu'on m'adressait souvent en
bonne place
vos smartphones sont cools par contre la
photo notamment la photo faible
luminosité c'est pas terrible
là c'est corrigé c'est vraiment des
points forts de la marque dire on écoute
notre communauté
une fois de plus c'est le cas et c'est
vraiment bien maintenant ça marche aussi
bien sur la caméra avant j'utilise
beaucoup pour fermer story sur instagram
d'ailleurs vous invitent à les rejoindre
sur instagram jeu monsieur anders corps
gros et franchement le rendu est cool ça
va tu gagnes pas trouvé c'était hyper
concentré quand même le professionnel
jusqu'au bout
aujourd'hui on a en bord de seine pour
parler avec de trottinettes petite
balade dans paris dans les pas mal c'est
bien par contre il fait super froid
pluie neige sèche ne pas tomber ne pas
tomber ne pas tomber
salut premier dans le trou voir l'armée
à strictement personne mais c'est un
tout petit déjà
on se fait plaisir en jus d'orange ne
savent pas les petits pains au chocolat
pour prendre du gratuit de l'eau parce
qu'il faut bien s'hydrater après une
soirée quand même assez mouvementée hier
soir regardez ça c'est justement ça
c'est un robot qui va imprimer
directement vos propres cellules on va
directement pour les grands brûlés ce à
compter du tout
le cartilage labour
à votre avis où est-ce qu'on est
aujourd'hui dans une salle de jeux en
réseau et peut-être vous chauffer mais
pas complètement
en réalité c'est hallucinant on est à
l'armée de terre on est là pour tester
des simulateurs d'entraînement
d'entraînement très très très très
sérieux pour s'entraîner au combat et ça
je vous en parle dès demain sur youtube
call of duty par les allemands sauf
qu'ils auraient été si bien simulateurs
d'entraînement de la moder et la
regarder on a même un volant pour trio t
on a de quoi faire il ya du matos c'est
justement le mode portrait fonctionne
pas trop mal à vous regarder le
détourage c'est assez clean deuxième
photo sur le mode portrait il à l'hélium
tout petit peu plus de mal si vous
regardez là sur le côté là entre les
doigts il a galéré un peu ici à tout
bien bien bien bien des tours et
pourtant on est stable à 845 et ça
marche plutôt pas mal là vers le visage
c'est pareil il a une petite zone soit
celle à peu près la même couleur que la
peau donc il a eu un petit peu de mal et
autres pans où il est un petit peu
galéré
c'est ici au niveau du pouce voyez sur
le dessus bon voilà là aussi un petit
peu c'est très très léger le contour est
pas pas parfait mais bon après dans
l'absolu vous le regardez comme ça
franchement ça fait le job
si vous avez regardé mon test du wan
plus système suit vraiment franchement
content de ce smartphone je trouve que
c'est vraiment une belle bête belle
autonomie performance c'est vraiment un
vrai flash schiller toujours dur à
prononcer la plaque chip killer par
contre ça marche bien et je vous dis le
fait d'avoir des photos qui sont
vraiment améliorée one plus à continuer
à gagner des fans aller encore plus loin
en tout cas pour l'instant c'est le
smartphone que j'utilise au quotidien et
je vous dis si vous cherchez un bon
photophone à des tarifs qui sont
raisonnables en dessous de 600 euros
celui ci est cool c'est pas le meilleur
photophone on a des smartphones qui sont
bien meilleurs mais plus cher le mail 20
pro par exemple et au sus il beaucoup
plus cher mais je trouve que si on veut
vraiment un smartphone qui est vraiment
équilibré en termes de performances en
termes d'autonomie en termes de photos
vidéos
là franchement on a vraiment un
excellent modèle et si vous intéresse je
vous ai mis le lien en bas d'un
description maintenant à vous de me dire
que vous entends c'est comment vous
trouvez ce une piste est ce que vous
l'avez essayé est ce que vous trouvez
cas une belle amélioration par rapport à
ce qu'on a pu connaître avant que chez
la marque
et est-ce qu'au final si vous l'avez pas
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter alia vous devez vous marrer tous
ces commentaires on s'en vient très
bientôt ce que vous allez voir il ya
plein de nouveautés il ya plein de trucs
et lâcher un colis qui monstrueux qui
arrivent et montre ce truc
il ya salle c'est énorme ça c'est une
énorme enceinte je suis bluetooth wifi
enfin un truc de ouf j'ai plein de matos
qui encore arrivé donc franchement on a
de quoi faire donc je vous invite à vous
abonner à me rejoindre
et si vous voulez connaître toute l'actu
des smartphones la playlist apparaît
vous pouvez les regarder vous ferez
plaisir de découvrir toutes les
nouveautés voilà je vous embrasse soyez
sages et à très bientôt
ciao
m